you
hi everyone it's Jerry I'm on chess comm
and I just got paired up playing any 500
games so I better get rolling
no increment here we have French defense
and let's strike at the tail and I've
been here before I'm gonna start with
Queen b6 and look for this idea get rid
of my light square bishop I think it
could still just go straight in for this
and I think it's a wise decision to get
rid of the tension all right I'm gonna
go straight in for this they might have
this as an idea
soon a d5 advance I'm guessing that's
the direction White's going in
okay so prop you just take I am for the
moment up upon so I could consider Queen
here um it's actually a little bit
appealing I may be able to get the
Queen's off yeah let's give it a go
mm-hmm
gotta make a decision yeah let's give
this a shot all right so it's completely
awkward waters here I don't have any
intention of really hanging onto the
pone but just gonna give this one a
whirl
Queenie - I could play Queen d3 if
they're really trying to avoid the Queen
exchange may end up with the target here
on e 690 g5 comes to mind
so we'll see Queen takes Queen pawn
takes Knight d2 I mean I would take
right here so they'd have to resolve the
tension and what about Queen d3 here
yeah let's let's insist on a queen
exchange
I think she's all the more annoying on
d3 than she is on b3 so probably just an
immediate recapture here I think yeah I
think I could rely upon my Queens home
here I think she's an inconvenience I
think White has to eventually take if I
take care I'm inviting the knight in to
c4 so probably just hmm
let's go knight c6 a Knight g5 I may
have Knight d4 looking at night c2 I'm
also in a position to maybe queenside
castle I think they should take my queen
now I'll have a passed pawn and I think
I'll live now one good thing here is
that with this early bishop maneuver
okay so they're trying to avoid Oh Queen
exchange you're keeping Queens on the
board so Knight d4 and you have to take
my knight I think what about just
queenside castle okay so they're lining
up Bishop e3 and then rook to d1 hmm
let's go with this so I'm looking
five and g6 maybe Knight to f5 or even
Queen to f5 Queen if I would drop this
pawn we'll see fun tonight g6 right now
let's just run in for this yeah I have
pressure on e5 I may just go ahead and
try to win that pawn queen g5 would run
into these tempo tempo moves they are on
e6 at the moment King f7 there's Knight
g5 hmm okay let's go Queen f5 I think
this is the only way to really defend
ecigs
to grab here very messy I'm not a big
fan of my structure in the end even if I
win this pawn here yeah I think we
should just go straight in for this I'm
not going to take with the night because
there's this check here so I'm gonna run
with this and I should be trying to
castle as soon as possible I actually
like a queenside castle yeah so I better
get castled can't go Queen side now
Queen B 5 is interesting striking at b7
difficult to defend I think I could just
castle here this pawn is gonna follows
it up
okay king of seven it's very ugly
I think I maybe need to do it
hmm okay very ugly I'm gonna be dropping
upon maybe I could grab a - no really
what I would want to do let's keep going
fast I thought an immediate Bishop move
would have been best the bishop backs up
I don't even know if I should try to
defend this guy he isn't a pin h3 g4 is
an idea let's do this
opposite sides castling but I think I
have to try to maintain my queen
position okay yep the G file is gonna be
opened up but to give it a whirl it
releases some pressure on e6 this palm
could be captured but let's also look at
some positives here maybe I could give a
check against the White King capturing
an f4 I really want the Queen's off I've
been watching the Queen's off for some
time now and I'm just taking a peek at
the times it has flown right by 207 for
white so Rick g1 Queen f5 Bishop takes
pawn I have this their king is a little
bit exposed as well rook f6 rook d8 are
some ideas maybe even Knight d4 on some
capture maybe having the king and queen
on the same file something I could take
advantage of bishop takes their okay
let's take here first I think I could
force the Queen's off let's take your
widths check and then here I'm up to
pawns actually very uh very surprised in
the end I am up a couple ponds so let's
neutralize the rook bring on all trades
I'm a fan and probably just push this
guy away huh do it alright on the clock
okay and what
stop for a couple exchanges he's maybe
just a little bit too active so here I
get the other rook hmm let's push right
there to be expected
let's keep pressure on this night I have
this square covered and probably just
keep pushing away huh yeah let's go one
more he can't move
even on the clock let's come all the way
back get this rook active I could play
Knight to e5 if he needs some more
support let's go here Knight g4 King f8
we don't want to run into Knight h6 he's
back on full strength now that out if
there's no pins on the G file I'm
looking at rook here or even Knight d4
to lend support to this pawn
let's centralize the night for starters
could play rook efore and also rook e to
I'm leaning more towards rookie two I
could do this Knight takes pawn I take a
rook first and then capture here so is
there any rush yeah let's let's exchange
and let's get one last piece involved
that way I could rely upon my knight
here just keep going up mm-hmm just be a
little bit careful let's do this smooth
kind of box out the knight watch out for
the knight g4 move and let's step up
here am i running into any tricks open
up let's get this guy going
g4 g3 thinking here was better even if
it winds upon even if white wins upon
I'm doing all right
yeah let's keep going
all right let's kill the night box him
out I'm on this pond and I could look to
transfer my rook and dislodge the king
at the same time let's go here and
they're gonna run out of time
less than two hmm okay I dodged a bullet
many bullets I believe in this one hmm
okay let's see let's take a quick pass
here let me flip the board taking a
quick pass before I even look at it with
the engine I have seen this idea before
where you don't move the bishop actually
no this idea of playing c4
I've seen this before but not in the
exact way that it was played in the game
there's also a Bishop e2 and then on
here this move notice if Bishop d3 and
then here pawn takes can be met with
captures and there is no time for d5
because I'm throwing a punch at the d3
bishop so this is just a quick point
about the two posts for the bishop if
he's on his stills home square or e2
this is an idea c4
capture and then d5 but a3 instead which
was preparing some b4 move to resolve
the tension between these two pawns okay
so I went straight in for the light
square bishop exchange and I probably am
just simply worse right around this
point I feel like no I don't know oh no
I think it's I think it's okay that part
but from here I have to probably improve
on something Queen b3 I mean I think a
simple approach for white is to do that
capture
and then play Knight to d2 and just get
this pawn back but I know it's a tough
position to weigh I mean if the Queen's
are on the board I see this as more of a
target it's maybe something that's not
so difficult for me to defend I have a
king of seven move it'll take a little
bit of preparation maybe I could get an
h6 but yeah my King position is a bit
vulnerable for as long as white still
has Queens on board whether it's Kings
side or Queen side it just feels a bit
shaky and so therefore did the Queen
exchange for a bet and maybe maybe even
here you know what because earlier I was
saying you know hey I don't want to take
the Queen because the night would
recapture and then has a fast track on
c4 or to get to c4 but maybe only after
he has developed maybe this is a moment
for me to just go for a queen exchange
and then play Knight here I'm already
liking it better I'm already not liking
this physician better Queens are off the
board I don't see how they get at this
pawn so easily here given a couple moves
here king f7 I can focus on this weak
point d4 even d3 my knight sighing that
square up as soon as I throw a rook on
the D file there's some nice squares I
could be working with b3 d3 d4 yeah and
you know what let me just kind of note
it to myself in a different way if I'm
taking the Queen here it's true I'm
helping light to develop but how well
developed a piece is a bishop on d2 here
I'll probably end up just having to move
again especially since this is a
completely open file and white will be
putting a rook on it and well before the
rooks can see the bishop will have to
move so maybe I shouldn't have been so
locked into this idea of hey I don't
want to take the Queen here because I'm
helping develop the bishop it's a
different story
if you know I'm capturing the Queen and
developing the night because as
mentioned he's on his way to a fantastic
square a night on c4 would be just
really really really good
okay probably should have captured the
Queen at this moment but didn't in now
white is just two moves away from
finally kicking my queen and completing
development so I don't know if I don't
have something here right away I don't
see how it could be better here
you know Queen F for avoiding the Queen
exchange was nice and then yeah I should
be busted here you know I'm one move
behind before I have my Brooks connected
but mmm so much more behind development
wise because both the rooks are already
functioning this is just a dead pawn at
any moment after I Castle they play f4
and I guess that was to stop this pawn
grab on h2 yeah maybe that's what I
would have had if the announce I don't
think that there's any great discovery
here for white you know any of this like
I'm taking I could be inserting some
checks if the bishop is pulled off of
this diagonal so maybe there wasn't a
great discovery
hmm we'll see what the computer saying
right around here but it certainly felt
uncomfortable I want a pond and I was
able to get the Queen's off this wasn't
a good decision at the end of the day
here to take the pawn because I have the
capture and then the forest Queen
exchange and I'm just up to clear pawns
that are perfectly healthy so I think
white should have done something
different right around here this was
still an interesting idea h3 g4 just to
rip open another file towards my king so
it's one of these if you say a go with
me and at least try this try to show
that the open or half open G file is uh
is going to be something
but I don't know I think there's a some
other approach probably here instead of
the h3 g4 idea one that maybe says you
know what
how about g3 I have a fine structure
you're not getting at f4 g3 in a way is
securing the king not going to be able
to give a good check on this diagonal
and then something like Bishop f2 and he
is bound to drop I don't know I don't
see how I'm saving him he's pinned for a
moment there I was just thinking maybe I
could push and get rid of this unhealthy
pawn for a perfectly healthy pawn but
that's just not happening here there's
more work required King in the corner
and well maybe even bishop f2 isn't best
as he's unprotected on that Square but
uh maybe something simple like this g3
and then focusing on the win of this
pawn is a good idea and let me I'm
actually up upon here I'm forgetting I'm
even up upon yeah hmm that's why I was a
bit surprised at that
after the Queen's were exchanged and
such I was like oh I'm up to pawn so I
lost count somewhere around at some
point in the game clearly but uh yeah
okay well we'll see what the computer
has to say in where there were maybe
some tactics missed and such give me a
minute and I'll bring it up okay
stockfish show us the way here what was
missed in this one
no great
changes here that's alright with this
idea okay and right around this point is
when I went in for a queen bee 397
instead not bad though wants to go for a
queen exchange queen d3 is okay I'm just
recapturing three four five six seven
I'm up a pond right now to keep this in
mind alright I develop and yeah wants to
go straight in for ninety four I pointed
this out if the knight moved but you
know I could go straight in for this you
know what kept me from it I didn't get
to voice it but I was just thinking okay
capture capture and then Knight here
well this never even entered my thought
process Knight h6
well I don't even have to do that do i
yeah you don't want this to hurt me no
no need to even allow that move but
Knight h6 into f5 and you know what if
I'm controlling e3 there is no you know
fast track to dislodge my Queen from her
post here hmm so the end result of
Knight d4 it's just a rough thought the
end result of Knight d4 may be that I
get to maintain my queen in this very
deep position and whites third rank here
and she she most certainly is a great
bother no King sight castle hmm and well
that's enough no King side castle can't
complete development for as long as
she's here so I could go straight in for
Knight d4 instead I got another piece
out my cheese sixes all right how are it
even ish Queen a5 and it wants
go with queenside castle hmm hey man I
just lost track of material in this game
I was thinking I need to get the pawn
back I could play this where you know I
don't have to grab this pawn and subject
this guy to some heat along the e-file
heavy piece pressure it's okay but you
know I don't have to do that they should
be seven maybe I was uh I don't know I
thought I'd be worse but I guess I'm
really not worse huh I don't know it
just felt I felt a little bit uneasy
here hmm nothing great was really missed
I mean a five and it likes the h3 idea
and it's a strong post for the Queen
keeps pressure on f4 h3 oh okay well
right around this point I was saying
maybe white can play it where they go g3
back the bishop up and win this guy I'm
still up this hunt and I could look for
some trades now hmm okay maybe not so
bad a game I I don't know I didn't feel
like it was a I felt like I didn't
really play it so well g4 you have to
just doesn't like this idea so something
other than that queen bee five strikes
at the beep on I was intending to do
something like this I mean I don't think
I could afford to lose the heart of my
Queen side structure that's what it
wants rook you're okay to be a and then
well they have some activity here huh I
got a do a six Queen b3 b5 hmm it's
gettin kind of sharp here
opposite sides castles Bishop f6 maybe
b4 yeah who knows how this one would end
it could turn evaluation could turn in a
blink
hmm
okay well I pick up another poem up to
and this is just not the right idea I
don't know they just grabbed on c5 and I
was able to get the Queen's off he takes
that for Queens our exchange now 94 is a
bit better I guess it's going to be a
approaching plus three two and a half
three after the Queen exchange cuz now I
have connected pawns plus two probably
given some time it'll continue to grow
but yeah I mean you know I don't think
anything was missed in this this endgame
part will have a quick pass through that
but huh interesting
I want to look at just one other thing
here and that is not Queen b3 but rather
97 D takes in Queen takes what would I
do
I'm curious what I would do on this
structural change d6 90 on c6 and then
the other one is playing here and we're
going to put pressure on this guy right
here could even look for maybe queenside
castle and it's tricky yeah it's tough
to know what what exactly to do with
this kind of structural change hmm and
the end of this Queen b3 idea maybe not
so bad Queen d3 hmm okay well yeah I
again I didn't think I played I thought
I get left some opening at some point in
this game but I guess that just wasn't
the case just making a quick pass in
this ending to see if there was anything
missed I think how I converted it was
fine I'm welcome to any even exchanges
and I just want to keep pushing my pond
deep and by doing so I'm restricting the
white pieces and yeah I don't think
anything is missed here getting the King
up
and as soon as the pawns are connected
yeah this is just busted
I guess one last thing is after I play
King here what about King e6 I was
saying during the game that even if this
pawn is one it should still be winning
for me Knight f5 check King d3 Knight h4
suppose the King comes over here rookie
4 Oh hmm I don't know if I would have
spotted that but let's just let's just
assume that I yeah let's just assume
that I wouldn't have spotted that and
that's on here said this move suppose
the King came over and I just pushed
here and I think that's what I would
have done yeah cuz you know what they
can't take care where we're just trading
into a King and pawn ending for some
reason I was thinking it's just like a
rook exchange and we still have a knight
each even if that was the case this pawn
is one and the rooks are off the board
this is still going to be winning it's
to clear pawns up and yeah in the end
they ended up losing on time but very
simple idea improving my King
inconveniencing their King maybe even
winning one of these guys but they lost
on time at the end okay
very different start to a game out of
the advanced French feel free as usual
to leave any feedback to this video in
the comment section below and as usual I
hope you got something out of it that's
all for now take care bye
you